Now that we have created some 2D fire liquids and smoke, let's take a look at creating their
3D counterparts.
Now creating the 3D version of these effects is very similar to creating the 2D version.
We right click inside of the content browser, we select Niagara System, and then from the
Create Niagara System dialog box, we look for Niagara Fluids, and then for this example,
we are going to select the grid, 3D, gas, and fire, and then hit the Create button.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we are going to right click inside of our content browser, then we are going to look
for our grid, 3D, gas, and fire, and hit Create NS underscore 3D gas fire.
And let's go ahead and double click on that to open it up.
Now this is going to look very similar to our other setup where we have a particle
admitter source, but instead of everything being done in one single admitter, we actually
have two.
And it's going to work like this.
So across the top here, this is our Niagara overview node.
This is going to show us things like exposed user parameters and properties and things
like that.
We have our particle source admitter.
This is going to work as our node for admitting the particles.
So however the particles are going to be admitted and then behave and move around the world
we will be taking care of inside of this node, the grid 3D gas master node, what that's going
to do is handle how the fluid simulation takes place.
Then we are going to take that fluid simulation and actually skin it to the particle source
admitter.
And the really cool thing about that is we now have the ability to make our particles
move in any which way we want and then have our simulation put on top of those particles
and by sim taking the simulation for the fluid and the simulation for the particles and making
this separation again allows us to do really, really interesting things like we can have
a trail of fire that follows a specific path or other interesting effects like that.
One of the other things to note when you click on the grid 3D gas master effect, the details
panel, even though it's going to be by default in admitter summary mode is going to be full
of options.
Don't worry about all of the options that are there.
The cool thing is is that you only need to adjust a few of them to actually really affect
how the look and the feel of the smoke and the fire reacts and that's because we're trying
to create something that is life like.
So remember when we are adjusting these things, we want to use very small values and we don't
want to push things too far or it's going to make stuff look weird because it's not going
to be physically correct.
And what we want to do is we want to be able to have things look maybe a little artistic,
but in the end still be physically accurate so that we can maintain artistic control and
we don't really have to worry too much about the feasibility of building the effect.
So let's go ahead and just pop over to the editor really quick and have a look at our
effect here.
So here we go.
Here's our fire effect.
So again, we have our particle, admitter source and this is going to work just like
it does normally if we do something like, I don't know, like change the sprite size
or something like that, it's going to change the size of the particles that are admitted
and then that's going to have a resulting on the end flame there.
So this is pretty standard, but then if we come over here to our grid 3D gas, this is
where we're going to be able to start adjusting all of the various properties for our gas
and smoke and fire simulation.
Now to make things a little bit easier for us, I'm going to highlight here some of the
things that you might want to consider adjusting to start with.
So first off, there is the pressure solve iterations by reducing that number.
You're going to be reducing the number of times that we solve for pressure and you're
going to make the fire well run a little faster, but it is not going to be as realistic.
If we increase this number, which it defaults to 200, I believe we are going to make the
fire have more pressure iterations and become more realistic at the expense of memory and
compute time.
So again, this is set to, I'm sorry, pressure solve, not 200 by default, it's set to three.
Let's go ahead and just set this or set this to three.
It's set to 10 by default.
I'm going to set it to three.
It's going to just make things run a little bit faster.
Our pressure relaxation, this is a, I'm going to turn this up to three here.
These values don't really correlate to anything that I got.
They're just values that I happen to pick as I was crafting things.
So feel free to adjust these or use other values.
These are just some areas that I know of that we can get some good results.
So then finally, I'm going to do our density buoyancy to 0.1 and our temperature buoyancy
to three or I'm sorry, not three, a 0.3.
And then our velocity dissipation, we're going to set that to a value of one.
All right.
And then we're just going to compile and save this.
Just to mess with some of the values to, you know, give us something to work with here.
And the other cool thing that we can do with this one is we can actually have this
be admitted right from a static mesh.
So all we need to do is place a static mesh and then inside of our particle system
underneath the static mesh here and the user parameters, we have this source actor.
We can actually sample this and use it to admit our particles from.
So let's take a look at that now.
So got this, we're going to go ahead and close this down.
There we go.
We're going to hit control space, bring our admitted in to the level.
So there we go.
And then I'm going to come up here to our quickly add to our shapes.
We're going to add a sphere, move this up and then make sure that we do have our
particles selected here.
There's our 3D gas.
And then we come down here.
Static measures will probably be collapsed.
So you need to un-collapse it.
And then we're going to select this and right there.
Oh, wrong one.
Not the one I wanted.
I wanted this sphere right here.
It will not work if it's not in the volume.
So we do need to make sure that that is in the volume.
But check that out.
It is now admitting from the surface of this sphere.
So that is actually really, really cool.
And if we were to, like, you know, move this around, you can see here, well, we
need to actually move both of them around in order to get the effect there.
But that's actually really, really cool.
So we've got that fire following that sphere and it's already set up to work like that.
All right.
So the next effect we're going to be taking a look at is liquid.
Now, in particular, we're going to be taking a look at our grid 3D flip hose.
There are a few other ones such as the flip pool and the flip splash.
And these work similar to their 2D counterparts here.
The other one, shallow water.
This is great for if we're simulating something like a small puddle or maybe a boat wake.
But for now, we're going to focus mainly on the grid 3D flip hose as this is one of the
ones that's a little bit cooler.
And also this is pushing modern VFX to its limits.
This is actually a really, really advanced technique and something that's really,
really cool and fun and interesting to work with inside of the editor.
So like we do with all of our other particles, we're going to go to the
content browser, right click Niagara system.
And then from the create Niagara system browser, we're going to select our grid 3D flip
hose and hit the create button.
Let's go ahead and do that now.
So make sure we delete, oops, delete this effect here.
And I was just saying that because I had deleted the sphere and it was referenced.
So I'm going to delete that.
And then we're going to come into our content browser, right click Niagara system.
We're going to look for our flip grid 3D flip hose and hit create NS underscore 3D.
Just call us water.
And let's double click on this to open it up.
Now, again, depending on how fast your system is and a whole bunch of other things,
this could take a little bit to open up.
It could take a little while to compile.
So just keep that in mind.
This is going to look a little bit different than what we are used to, even
though it is kind of similar.
Let me just move the details panel over a little bit here because we actually
have this grid flip.
And then there's going to be another one right over here.
And this other one, you're like, oh, it's got two.
It doesn't actually, this is another admitter that is used to create white water.
So we're going to focus on this other meter right here for now and look at the white
water one in just a little bit.
So again, remember, we are creating a natural phenomena.
So while this might look like it, absolute ton of parameters, there's not too
many that we actually need to adjust inside of here.
In fact, for this particular effect, many of the things that we need to adjust
are actually already exposed to us under user parameters such as our collision
velocity, our number of cells, max axis, this is going to control the quality of it,
the water height and the great extents.
That's pretty much all that we need to have exposed because remember, water is
going to work exactly the same way in the digital world as it does in the physical
one, because we are using the laws of physics to actually run this simulation.
Now, with that said, there are some properties that we need to be aware of so
that we can make sure that our water uses only the resources that it needs.
Now, the first thing that I'm going to do is enable this show bounds.
And what this is going to do is it's going to show us with this red outline here,
the maximum and minimum area that the simulation is going to take place in.
If I come over here to my world grid extents and I was to increase or decrease
these numbers, as you can see like this, what we've done here is we have taken
the height of that and instead of being 500 with a bunch of empty space up here,
we put it down to 400, which brings it way closer to the admission point.
Again, the reason that we're doing this is we don't ever plan to have water go
all the way up here.
So all that area is going to be unused inside of our simulation.
And just because it's used doesn't mean that it doesn't need to occupy memory.
So we want to bring this down as low as possible.
So let's look at how we can set this up now.
So inside of here, I'm going to close this because we don't actually need that.
I hit control space, bring in my water by just control dragging that in.
And again, by default, it's not actually going to show me the bounds.
So we come over here with it selected and we go to show bounds.
And there is the bounds for this particular object.
And then what I can do here is let's just set this as something like 300.
There we go.
And this also highlights something else, even though it is actually admitting
outside and it's cutting the bounds off, that's something that you need to be aware
of. You want to set this something low, but not so low that your
emission source kind of gets cut off or it starts to make things look unrealistic.
Now, some of the other things that we can adjust here, this
numb cells max per axis.
If I set this as something like 16, check this out.
It's going to give us this very wobbly and blobby looking water right there.
If I was to increase this to like 64, or let's just see what was the default.
I think the default was 92.
So let's try 128.
It's going to give us this very, very, very, very finite water
that actually is having problems pooling.
You can see here that the water is so fine that it's not actually collecting
with other stuff.
So we might need to turn this down to maybe like 100.
And there we go.
We get some better pooling action.
So just remember water and liquids is going to be really
balancing act between getting your settings and the performance just right.
Other thing to note here are pressure iterations.
This is going to control basically
how many pressure time, how many times pressure is used to
push the water around the world.
And the more we increase this, the more realistic results we're going to get.
Just remember though, as we increase this, it is going to crease the memory
footprint of our particular project.
So we might run into performance issues as we do that.
One of the other cool things we can do with the water is make it collide
with static meshes.
Now, all you need to do for this to work is just simply add the object
and make sure you have the tag collider added to it.
So we're going to come over here and we're just going to come down to our
quickly add to projects.
We're going to come to our shapes and add a sphere.
Now, with the sphere like this, notice that nothing is actually happening.
It's not actually doing anything.
But if I come to this, I search for my tag and we add the tag of collider.
And let me just move this now.
Check that out.
Look at that.
It's actually colliding with the water.
You can see here that the water is actually bouncing off of it now, going
around it instead of directly through it.
And again, I just added the tag collider.
Now you can also do this with the third person character or any other
skeletal mesh.
Just make sure that you have the tag collider added to your character blueprint.
If you don't have a character blueprint in your current project, you can add
a feature of content pack and then select the third person character.
Once you've added that look for the BP third person character blueprint, open it
up and then in the details panel, search for tag and add collider.
And let's do that now because right now, if I was to play this, nothing is going
to happen.
I'm just going to kind of sit here and not really collide.
So I'm going to hit control space.
We are going to look for our third person, our blueprint open to open it up.
Come over to our details panel.
We're going to search for tag and then we're going to add the tag collider.
Compile save.
Let's close that now and we hit play.
And we'll see here that as this starts to fill up, I will start to move the water around.
You can see I'm kind of doing it a little bit now.
And there we go.
As it starts to fill up, you can see I'm making a little bit more of a splash
note pun intended.
So let me close this off and I'm going to hit control R to stop that from rendering
because what I want to do now is I want to come back to our water here and I'm
going to enable this extra one right here and we'll do a compile and we'll do a
save and you can see already I've got the white water going on there.
So we're going to close this down.
And while that closes down, let's take a look at what's going to happen next.
So you can see here as I enter the volume, it's actually going to be displaced by the
water, the character.
We can also adjust the water height, which will allow the water to only be spawned to
a certain height.
This is fantastic.
If you want to use this to say fill a puddle of some particular area instead of having
to adjust how long the water lasts or figure out how to get rid of extra water or
something like that, you just simply adjust the water height to be the height of
whatever object it is that it is meant to occupy.
And the simulation will take care of the rest.
Also, the water does react like real water.
As you'll see here in just a second, when that white water splashes or when the water
gets displaced by the character, it's actually creating particles that are coming off
of the main water as a real splash in real life would be.
So it's a very, very complex simulation we have going here.
So let's close this down.
There we go.
Oops, we don't want to close the whole thing down.
We're going to hit play.
And there we go.
Look at that.
We've got the white water coming off of it.
So it's splashing around.
And then as I as I move through, I will kick up more white water.
And again, these are just the default settings.
So it might not look as realistic as it could, but this is just the default.
We can come in here and adjust, you know, how long the white water stays around
and all types of other things.
But yeah, look at this.
We're getting some really, really great results inside of here.
So all right, that is going to bring us to the end of this part.
And the next part of our tutorial, we're going to take a look at how we can utilize
some of the built in features of Niagara to help optimize our smoke, liquid and
fire effects by rendering their complex effects down to a texture and then using
a sub UV particle to help play that back in real time, giving us the illusion of
this really complex matter taking place.
But in fact, it's just a flip book playback.